Skyler's in Spokane Washington hi Skyler
how are you hey I'm good Dave how are
you better than I deserve what's up um
so I recently got introduced to you
around June July this year and that
started my debt snowball and then paying
off my student loans and and how you
instruct it and how old are you my mom
I'm 28
good for you okay yeah and my mom she's
noticed that I've been paying off my
student loans and I have one private
loan that is on the bottom of my debt
snowball and she disagrees with how I'm
going about paying off my my dad because
I'm not a 28-year old man and you pay
your own bills right I gotta okay so
what businesses are some of your
mother's none besides that she has
access to my bank account when I opened
it up after eat I opened it up and when
I was in high school and today you're a
man right your mommy doesn't need to be
in your business anymore you're a
28-year old man right go down there and
change it right now okay okay and then
just mom I appreciate your concern I
love you but this is what I'm doing
right and and she's helped me out in the
past before when when things been tight
and well they're not going to fight
anymore now you're getting out of that
all right if she says she supports you
and you live in her household then
that's one thing but if you're a free
moral agent a 28 year old standalone
independent man then this is just mom
who's concerned who is overstepping her
boundaries that's all that's all it is
and she loves you she's she means well
but she's just noisier than crap right
right yeah I mean it's not she's not a
bad person she loves her little boy but
start to you
to her she's the little boy that used to
do whatever when you were eight right
but now your 20s you missed that point
right and this is normal for mommies by
the way sometimes I have to remind my
wife that my son is a grown man 26 and
he's married and this is what's known as
a none-of-your-business
you know I have to remind my wife of
that sometimes I don't do it very often
but she's pretty good about it but
mommy's love their voice and sometimes
it's hard for them to grow up but the
hard to let them grow up but it's your
it's your stance as a man to handle this
and you just lovingly put a boundary up
and mom I'm gonna pay off my debts and I
got a plan and I'm working it hard and
you know yeah I think you're think
you're gonna be proud of it someday mom
and you just move on just like just like
a friend who disagrees with the way you
vote right you got a friends that vote
different than you dadgum minefield but
but I mean you know point being that I
love them anyway and they're gonna vote
how they're going to vote and I'm a vote
on my vote I still like them mm-hmm I
don't disqualify you from friendship due
to the way you vote right right I don't
I mean I'm not that narrow-minded I get
a little more intellect then that so
anyway that's uh that's the way I would
look at it is just look at that way she
just doesn't agree with you know what if
you bought a blue car and she liked blue
cars I mean it's the same thing okay you
know it's you get to decide you bought
the car it's your money your life you're
28 and you know that kind of stuff so
I'm glad she loves you I'm glad she's
concerned I'm not being mean to her but
she's just you know she's poking around
his stuff that she doesn't need to be
poking around and you need to stop her
from doing it so you can have a life
gently and kindly I'm not suggesting
you'd be rude to your mother that's
against the rules around here never be
rude to mom but uh but we can put
boundaries up and gently kindly firmly
reminder how things work and that's what
you do here hey thanks for the call open
phones at triple eight eight to five
five two to five I'm gonna have to ask
Megan Meeker about that one that's an
interesting thing that just popped into
my head I don't know that I wonder if
there is I think I'll just don't I'll go
ahead and stir some of you up on Twitter
are you ready I kinda think I'm not
positive not rotate take
stand on this I'm going to ask her then
it's harder for moms to let go of their
sons than his dad's to let go of their
daughters I kind of think that because
well I've just observed that with some
of my buddies too they marry off their
daughters and they still love their
daughters and the special place in our
heart the little girls always got you
wrapped around their little finger but
the need for me to go interrupt my
daughter's life is very minimal except
to the extent she works for me but I
mean but I mean in terms of her personal
life to go over trotting around in my
muddy boots through her house so to
speak it's very minimal I think maybe
it's a southern thing I don't know
that's it I'll have to ask Megan Meeker
about that she's the parenting expert
and she can tell us how that works she's
wrote strong father strong daughters and
strong mother strong sons and all that
kind of stuff so interesting interesting
stuff